We make assumptions about people all the time. It's not necessarily a bad thing,
but how often are we actually right about the assumptions we make and how often
are we right about the assumptions other people make about us to find out.
We decided to put someone in the hot seat and have 100 strangers,
rate them one to 100 based on various levels of first impression in doing so we
would hopefully be able to see how different ways of communicating could
drastically change the way we perceive others. Welcome to one-to-one hundred.
Hi everyone. My name is DJ Cornado. Um, I'm a college student.
I'm 20 years old and I also am in a fraternity.
What would you rate yourself? Uh,
I'd give myself like a high B,
so probably like 87 for intelligence. Yeah. Alrighty.
Yeah. Our first group is just going to be looking at you.
I don't know if I come off as, as an intelligent person, I guess we'll see.
It really depends on the questions that they asked me and stuff like that. So
Can you show what kind of pants you're wearing? If you're wearing pants,
are you wearing underwear? Can we see your closet? Can we see your clothes
Organized?
The faculty had fiercely present him,
made him feel like he was more into,
rather than academics. He looked sweet and like, you know,
typically like whenever you like, see people in classes, you're like, Oh,
this person is smart and he didn't have glasses,
but like he still looked like he was like.
[Inaudible].
Uh, I think, I think I took a hit, uh,
when they all saw kind of like the frustrated flag at the end. Um,
but like other than that really, really nice people. I liked it.
Well, yes, yes.
Oh, we ain't got that many pictures. That's all right.
Oh, he's been to Barcelona.
He is very independent. Yeah.
Independent because he only got like one to like, not to Pepperdine though.
That don't mean nothing, but this one doesn't have any of the, um, activism,
posts, Adrian.
[inaudible] just travels.
To me. Um, if someone's traveling, especially if they're in college,
all that means to me is they have the means to travel. Like there's no,
like depths like that picture. It was like answer ban with a capital D again.
Well, I would hope that he, you know,
he has a lot of knowledge because since he travels so much,
I would hope that he knows the culture and it's not just for show.
And he did travel a lot and he seems like someone who is way up going.
So I would assume that he knows a lot about different cultures and how different
people work.
It was pretty like deeply rooted and everyone's experiences,
whether they want to call it or not on how they perceive having the means to
travel and, um,
prioritizing travel over like studying or an internship.
I would have scored him higher if there were more social justice posts.
We're to.
We'll move on to the next section, then conversations over voice.
Hi Sam. Hi. Hi, my name is David. Nice to meet you. Nice to meet you, David.
Um, what are you? So, yeah, um,
I'm a student of integrated marketing communications, um,
at Pepperdine university in Malibu. All right, cool. What's your GPA?
My GPA is a 3.7 right now, so yay. Okay. Okay.
Where did you actually go? I went to Wheaton college in Chicago.
Um, but now I'm a law student.
And you get your news from, um,
it just really depends. I try and honestly do BBC,
just because I feel like they're the least bias. Um,
I don't really like bleed reading, uh, politically charged, uh,
articles from either spectrum. So yeah,
I get a lot of news from BBC for sure. Um,
so what do you think about like COVID and, uh,
like Trump's administration trying to like silence of data and like yeah.
Try and all that. Yeah. I, I don't agree with it whatsoever. Um,
I think everyone needs to be wearing a mask, a self quarantining. Um,
do you have any hobbies? Yeah, hobbies. Um, I love reading. Um,
I love reading anything from nonfiction or fiction.
What would you say is your favorite book? That's the great Gatsby.
That was just my favorite. Growing up.
You have very good taste. Great.
Gatsby is actually my favorite book as well as for my whole life.
Oh man. I hate the Greek guy. Oh, well.
Where do you prioritize most in your life? Um, I would say family, you know,
I wouldn't be where I am without them. Um, so I'm a very family oriented person.
What do you think denotes,
like someone who is truly intelligent? Um, I think that,
you know, it's not so much just academically, you know, if you're,
if you're book smart, uh, quote unquote, book smart.
I don't think that's a true judgment, uh, intellect at all. I think, you know,
a real judgment would be, um,
whether or not that person applies himself to whatever they're passionate about
and are able to problem solve throughout their journey.
Even a pretty high score,
because I was able to have a conversation with him about what his work
was.
And he said that he was in a business field and I feel like that involves a
lot of education.
We talked a lot about, um,
his education experience and just the way he talked about it.
He was very confident, but not in like a arrogant way, I guess.
Hi. Hi. How are you? Good, good. How are you? I'm good. I'm Darien.
Nice to meet you, Darien. My name is David virtual and virtual handshake,
virtual handshake. So I started, yeah,
of course. Thank you. Or done your dreams.
I dreams. Um, I hope to one day own my own marketing firm. Um,
I would say that's probably like my 15 to 20 year dream.
I believe you can do so much. I appreciate it. Do you know,
like your States and capitals? Um, I can name all the States.
I don't know about every single capital,
but I can name every state what can be broken,
but it's never how well it can be broken, but it's never held, um,
spirit a promise. Promising was people.
I do feel that you connect well with people like you very easily,
or like sometimes it's really hard to, yeah, I would say I,
uh, you know, a blessing and a curse. I run my mouth 24 seven,
so I just get talking. And so hopefully, you know,
that makes other people kind of more comfortable to be able to communicate with
me as a person.
It has to happen for change.
Like it was something you could suggest it could make a change.
Um, I think it starts with, you know,
this newer generation teaching the generation after us,
what ideals we should have as Americans. And that, you know,
that if you believe that there isn't a problem with racism in America right now
that you're completely wrong because there is a problem. Um,
so I think the ultimate change would definitely be this generation taking
accountability for, you know,
the older generations actions and passing those ideals that we want our children
to have in the next generation. So, yeah. All right. And that is two minutes.
Yes, sir.
A hundred for me is like someone who is already great.
Like they are already thinking outside of just themselves and just the things
they learned in walks, they are able to grow.
They kind of seemed nervous when I was talking to him and asked him a question.
And I think like he was just talking really quickly.
So I didn't really see him as that intelligent.
So I think that, you know, a camera or not, like,
I think when I was able to actually communicate back and forth with the person,
um, that they, you know, found value in that. Um, and I think that, you know,
my social media appearance and, um,
just my general like room appearance and just me without talking. Um,
I don't think that was too bad, but it didn't really show who I was as a person.
So yeah, if you can guess within three points,
either direction of the average score you got today based on the
interactions you had, then you win $100. Oh, wow.
Okay. Um, I'd go with,
I'm going to say 86.
Oh.
Wow. Okay. Interesting. What do you think,
um, caused the disparity? Um,
I think it was definitely maybe the first two groups. Um,
I definitely saw that like the fraternity thing came into play and I knew that
was going to happen. Um,
hopefully I kind of broke that stereotype a little bit today.
Looking back at it,
I feel like I judged him a little bit too harshly and I feel like everyone
else did as well because it's social media.
And I think we were being pessimistic instead of optimistic.
What would you rate yours?
Oh, like a 20.
If he knows better as a marketing major, he should know how to sell himself.
Essentially. He didn't have photos with friends.
He didn't have photos with animals, pets.
He wasn't posting about all of the horrible things we could have going on in the
country right now, which we need to be talking about. He's just like, yeah,
here's the, my favorite shots of me in Italy. I definitely get.
That fraternity and I guess, stories, um, aren't really, uh,
seen as like the brightest on campus and whatnot. Um, as in terms of like,
you know, stereotypes among Greek life and whatnot,
I think they're all pretty justifiable. I mean,
hopefully I was able to kind of change a little bit of the stereotype least for
myself. Um, and yeah, like I overall love the experience. I,
um, appreciate everyone for.
Pardon it. And yeah.